[Musique]
sur manifester parce qu'on en a marre de
se faire marcher dessus on en a marre
que continuer nous dire des propos du
style c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans mais
derrière compass rien de concret de
suffisant pour nous aider dans ce conte
demain concrètement ces deux shows des
réponses pédagogiques et des réponses
sociales ont mal être opéré aujourd'hui
pédagogique c'est bien ouvrir les
universités bien sûr de manière adaptée
on a bien conscience qu'on va pas
reprendre aussi retrouver une situation
normale tout de suite et ensuite c'est
un plan d'urgence de 1 5 milliard
d'euros pour répondre à la précarité qui
permettent d'augmenter les bourses et
les aides au logement tout juste
maintenant parce que la précarité
extrême elle nous touche maintenant on a
besoin d'une réponse maintenant pas dans
six mois pas dans cinq ans comme à
chaque fois on nous on nous le promet
tait
étudiants ont perdu leur job ces
derniers mois que cela qui sanitaires et
depuis plusieurs mois avec les autorités
le jeune ex manifeste pour avoir pour
les moins de 25 ans parce que
aujourd'hui il ya plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]